a portion of this video is sponsored by
google hello i'm gav in this video we're
going to be using slo-mo to see what
happens
when you shatter a wine glass using
nothing but sound
we're going to find out the resonant
frequency of this glass
sounds like that we're going to play
that sound extremely loudly
at the glass until hopefully it gives up
on life
and shatters all over the place behind
me is an extremely fast phantom
a bright light and a very loud speaker
that's all we need let's crack on crack
on
my phone has no headphone jack so i've
wheeled out this old
busted ipad which is running a tone
generator app will find the frequency
and we'll play this
through this amp into this two inch
compression driver
with a little bit of pvc on the end
which as you can see i've watched the
saw job
but it should be enough to focus the
sound nicely into the side there
backlighting it with this bad boy and
filming it with the phantom tmx
7510 a very fast new camera and we'll be
starting out
at 82 000 frames a second at 720p
aim the monitor towards me so i can see
what i'm looking at
needs some safety goggles and some muffs
did you see that the light just died
that was it
i was like less than a minute away from
filming that
okay this light is on its last legs i
think maybe too much glitter
first i'm going to use this piece of
paper just to see if i'm getting close
one of two things will happen here
the glass will break or the speaker will
yeah about that seems to be good i'm
gonna take this out
let's crank it 504 hertz
[Music]
whoa wow just blew off the back
blimey it was i could see it with my
eyes how much it was warping there that
was nuts
just exploded didn't it oh look at the
bend it just looks like liquid be
interesting to see where the break
starts will we do the stem or near the
top very much doubt it would start
randomly in the middle it's going to be
a point of
weakness oh seem to be
right at the front there wow still
extremely fast even at 82 000 frames a
second that was fast
it absolutely and it changes the
resonant frequency it's no longer
vibrating because it's not the right
shape anymore
okay so that was very cool and i think
now i want to either increase the speed
and go closer
or perhaps film it from above trying to
decide what i want to do first i think
we'll go for a faster speed
so we'll get rid of that one
[Music]
to find the frequency of this one
they're all slightly different um
all the ones from the same box seem to
be very similar sort of
between 500 and 510 hertz but we'll find
that doing the uh little paper trick
you also can play the sound into uh your
phone
and there's apps that will tell you the
frequency so now in order to increase
our speed i've had to massively reduce
the vertical resolution
so it's now only 320 pixels high which
is unfortunate for this subject
because it's a tall one not a wide one
which means
the left and the right of frame are a
complete waist
and the top and the bottom are missing
what we really need is for our subject
to
be this way on the sensor not this way
there's a very advanced
method you can use with these cameras to
do that
and that is turning the camera outside
and filming that way
so we'll do that now
it's now basically the world's fastest
tick-tock camera
okay so now we are making much better
use of the sensor
just skimming the sides here and we are
at
187 000 frames a second
with a two and a half microsecond
exposure
okay 506 seems pretty good let's try it
okay absolutely bizarre thing happened
there the vibrations from the speaker
caused the trigger button to slip off
the table
and trigger the camera right as the
glass broke so we only have the very
beginning of this glass crack
[Music]
this one's a bit more foggy looking
[Music]
[Music]
oh
that's the all right this glass
is stubborn um and it's blown this
so i'm just gonna put a new coil in here
unfortunately
okay we should be good again
[Music]
it's just a complete explosion
oh it went from the bottom wow
this is so interesting like once it
started cracking
all the new branches that start at this
speed we're
slowing down one second to over two
hours
it really does show you how fast the
cracks are
when moments later and by moments i mean
you know thousandths of a second later
it just looks paused everything the
glass actually
spreading out in the air is so much
slower
than the cracks moving through the glass
and you can actually still see
even in the pieces that have come apart
they still
carry that frequency that they were
vibrating at
just a few thousandths of a second ago
and still see the wobble very cool oh i
really like that one
i've seen this done many times before
and i've seen it in slow-mo before it's
actually a classic subject to shoot in
slow-mo i've never seen it this slow
though
it's very interesting
all right i've got to stop watching it
we'll be here all day do you want to try
this one with liquid in just so i can
film the surface and see what the liquid
does
maybe get some cool shapes it won't
break the thing because
the glass won't be able to warp in the
same way but
it might be interesting to film
[Music]
this looks very similar to the video we
did on the chinese
spouting bowl from a few years ago
this is the part of the video that is
sponsored by google however there is
more slo-mo
at the end if you'd like to stay tuned i
use the internet all the time to find
out information or just to seek out the
answers to
questions i have at 2am but sometimes
it's difficult to figure out which
information is useful
and which is a load of old google is
really committed to putting the highest
quality information
first and google search has some great
features to help you assess
just how reliable the information that
you're reading is but it's still
important to think very critically about
the way we use the internet
especially with regards to information
in the recent years i've been very
interested in renewable energy
potentially even
thinking about investing in solar power
however there is
so much misinformation out there in
regards to renewable energy and that's
why it's so important when you or i are
searching online
that we try not to take the truth of
search results for granted and instead
try and understand all the information
for ourselves using my interest in solar
energy as an example a lot of the time
it's important
how you phrase a question when searching
online for example
how much money will solar save me may
skew the results and you won't actually
know
or learn about the subject in general so
a better phrasing of that question might
be
pros and cons of solar panels then
you're more likely to find
results where both sides are presented
and you actually get the whole picture
instead of straight down one path
and that's it really just a little psa
there from google but a very important
one
and i feel like that mindset will
continue to get even more important
as time goes on and technology gets more
advanced big thanks to google for
sponsoring that segment
now we'll return to the action because i
haven't broken everything in this video
yet
let's continue okay i've moved the set
up to the floor we're now looking
straight down at the rim of the glass
[Music]
just so much stress
why did it break that time pull at the
bottom again
[Music]
back at 187 000 frames a second
[Music]
i just love the way the frequency causes
that wonderful sort of top to bottom
squish
and then left to right squish
immediately after back and forth
it really gives you a sense of time
between the flexes because this one
cracks at the bottom
there's enough time for all of the
movement at the top
to transfer from a side to side smush to
a
top to bottom smush and that's all while
the crack is traveling up so you
actually still get
the continued flex of the rim of the
glass even though the bottom of the
glass is
catastrophically failed
[Music]
whoops well there we have it some
immensely slow footage of a classic
science experiment very interesting to
see it so much slower than i've seen it
before
and i've blown up my final voice coil i
just started firing smoke all over the
room
which was pretty funny and we've
devastated several wine glasses
make sure you subscribe if you like
slow-mo that's what we're all about
thank you very much for watching and
i'll see you in the next one
cheers
i missed the bucket